[Música]
boa noite
[Aplausos]
começamos bem em falar bem é isso que a
gente queria estar de parabéns é isso
que a gente queria
boa tarde pessoal a desanimar bem
desanimado está desanimado já tentar de
novo boa tarde pessoal ai ai melhorou dá
pra fazer um show de humor aqui pra você
está em um show de comédia então se só
tem pode ir à vontade não precisa ficar
com vergonha da risada tem gente tem uma
risada engraçada é casada pode ter pap
já é isso aí é pra pixel pode pode ter
vontade de vergonha não fica o governo
também tem risadinha aquela risada que
abrir o apetite linha
eu sou aí vai não tem vergonha acho que
a gente não tem a vergonha do das vogais
também a risada das vogais qual queremos
qualquer lado as vogais cargo lhe dá
risada das vogais é o tipo de risada que
a pessoa sorri parecendo que ela tá
rindo em uma tocaia porque ela vai lá a
a assim sabe uma coisa impressionante
mas não estou a entender muito bem não
precisa ter vergonha na risada se só tem
deixa os problemas falar deixa os
boletos de fora depois preocupa com isso
apesar de ser um evento sério chegou o
momento de descontração então vamos rir
vamos rir com a gente até porque está
filmando e se vocês virem ajuda a gente
né
fica muito mais bonito no vídeo a gostei
desse capa guerras rapaz que se chama
ele derrapou como diego tudo bem disse o
mestrando da nossa platéia
isso vai ser o rei da nossa patek hoje
show de beleza tipo assim diego se você
achou uma coisa engraçada que você vai
fazer e vai acelerar a moto com br
mas assim se a gente veio aqui conta uma
piada que é muito muito muito mais
engraçada
além de dar risadas vai fazer o que
venho ver a vontade dentro de fazer o
que é que é isso
claudinha está fazendo papel de então
inclusive é o seguinte eu digo se tive
essa vontade dentro assim de dentro do
seu útero de você bater palma
você bate palma mas gente não deixa o
diego no vácuo por favor não está certo
o diego vai bater palma agora vai de
erro
olha a cara dele parece um carteiro na
porta da sua casa não pode quando o
coleguinha puxar palma vai todo mundo
junto entender o pai diego agora todo
mundo fica mais bonito ver no vídeo que
com a beleza com a maravilha parece
parece que o show é bom parece que o
show é bom para avastar divertido mesmo
milhão de t
carlin hoje nós temos um tema muito
especial que se marcos sinapses
eu fico pensando só no que nesse quesito
do tema sinapses é porque a minha vida
um pouco meio difícil de eu poder lidar
com as conexões que eu tenho com as
pessoas às vezes eu acho que as pessoas
não entendem o que eu quero dizer porque
por exemplo eu tenho uma namorada que a
gente tem uma conexão muito boa só que
aí teve uma época da vida que ela estava
muito muito invocada com aquele clichê
lingüiça dele o passe é alguém que
conhece a mulherada conhece mais do que
conhece o grupo de boi em pé mas ela
tava muito invocada com essa questão dos
50 tons de cinza eles 50 tons mais
escuros cinquentões liberdade e eu
lembro que eu pensei eu vou fazer alguma
coisa diferente é só que eu sou magro
não gosta
eu falo para ele é incrível ele consegue
ficar com quem ele quiser
essa é todo mundo parece apaixonado ele
mas até eu seria apaixonado nele se o
cara fosse em busca de helicóptero
pousou no valim de melo ano faz o que
ele quiser deixar de bater pode bater
onde helicóptero que é isso daí eu fui
no sex shop para poder comprar um
negócio meu namorado pra gente poder
tentar ser um pouco ali né
eu compro algema comprar um par de
algemas e entreguei para ela e falei
assim a turma
você pode fazer o que quiser comigo ela
olhou pra mim e eu posso fazer o que eu
quiser pleito
entreguei ela repreendeu assim mais uma
cabeceira da cama e eu fiquei na posição
assim eu sei que não é sexy mas isso não
é o intuito né
e eu fiquei assim na cama eu tava desse
jeito desse jeito aqui preso e ela lá de
barco assim na do pé da cama virou fã se
eu posso fazer tudo que eu quiser mesmo
tudo eu sei que ela vai subindo assim
ela foi subindo ela foi passando assim
ela vai subindo devagarzinho e chegou
até ela pulou fiquei meio sem entender
ela foi subindo subindo subindo quando
ela chegou no meu rosto ela espremeu
todos os meus cravos porque eu acho que
não teve a nossa conexão ele tem às
vezes nem eu entendo que não teve aquela
conexão aquela coisa boa e uma das
coisas também que eu fico tentando uma
conexão aproximação é com o meu pai
porque com a conexão com o meu pai é um
pouco difícil é meu pai é aquele cara
meio bravo ele é muito bravo é aquele
tipo de pessoa que não fala nada e só
respira o desse jeito sabe é muito ele é
grosso se não tem argumento ele pode
qualquer ele bateu uma vez na vida uma
vez eu nunca vou esquecer dessa vez que
eu ganhei do meu pai
ele deixava andar de bicicleta só até o
primeiro poste acima da rua
só que nesse dia eu pensei vou dar a
volta no quarteirão tava valente estava
lá e pensei só valem vida louca porque
eu não posso dar a volta no quarteirão
vou ficar andando só tem sido um tanto
em dianópolis
você sabe aquele gente sabe os 300
indianápolis é alguma pessoa pegou uma
pessoa está bem é samba bom de
referência temos que mudar a piada
e aí eu lembro que eu dei a volta no
quarteirão assim quando cheguei na
esquina
meu pai estava com o dedo apontado pra
dentro de casa e outro segurança correia
naquele momento do pisca-pisca trancou
sabe eu pensei vou apanhar muito mas eu
pensei se eu passar correndo dali e foi
no canto e ele não me pega aquele que eu
fui de bicicleta no cantinho e meu pai
deixou de ser meu pai virou indiana
jones
ele deu uma chicotada aqui no meu sutiã
eu levantei chorando assim peguei a
bicicleta não posso nem da volta nem viu
já tem 25 anos
é muito ruim se gente fica tentando
entender um pouco melhor as questões das
relações humanas que a gente tem de
relacionamento seja com a família com
certeza e você luciano eu inclusive fui
pesquisar o que as sinapses muito bons
ea comunicação das células muito pra
existe essa comunicação o ponto a eo b
tentar na mesma sintonia tentar na mesma
vai exatamente que normalmente é o que
não acontece no casamento que eu sou
casado ea gente às vezes a esposa
falando uma coisa a gente tá entendendo
outro dia ela olhou pra mim pro amor me
pega de gatinha na nuca desta noite aí
bebê leite caixa de areia
a gente tá diferente ea gente não se
comunica da forma ideal
teve um dia que a gente estava lá na
[Risadas]
minha mulher me deixa nervoso e me deixa
nervoso só porque existe o erro na
comunicação então tem uma coisa que ela
não me comunicou antes do casamento é
que o cabelo liso dela era chapinha
gente estão na tela que é tanta que ela
é viciada em fazer chapinha juntei
dinheiro um ano pois a nossa lua de mel
como rio de janeiro chegando a 30º andar
net um xampu em cima da mesa unidos
aquelas que elas cama de que para fazer
coisas grupal assim bagunça cabe 865 na
cama romântica mas uma pequena janela
mostrei para o corcovado cristo redentor
foi amor que você acha disso tudo ela
chegou e já leva 20 em bater palma vai
junto gente é isso aí sim a gente passa
por complicações é triste por exemplo
depois do casamento um que eu descobri
que mulher só tava 11
eu achava que esse senhor divino é ser
maravilhoso chamado mulher era
impossibilitado soltou um fato fedorenta
eu descobri da melhor maneira para
flávio fedorento a nota essa eu descobri
isso da pior maneira possível mulher
estava com dor de barriga foi descer da
cama ela só tem 16 pontos na sequência
assim ó poupou a votação a diesel sons
dos caminhoneiros a falar senão ela
falou assim eu estou soltando um pouco
falei 'ah você não fala e vestiu branco
cachoeira revellion posso ter um com
agora não foi total com se pode matar
fauna ea flora do jeito que tá fazendo
acabar com o fogo hora né que quer
acabar com o folclore não depois do
casamento que eu fui comunicado
em comunicado aquela roncava é muita
surpresa da usal mulher ela ela rouba a
minha mulher nunca e eu falei assim não
pode existir uma falha de comunicação eu
vou falar para ela foi a pior besteira
que eu fiz na minha vida
fiquei um mês sem fazer bobagem nem no
dia ela me mandava e menu dhifalla amor
me manda irmão lucilara exata não nem no
dia 9 mandado que desesperado um mês sem
nada a sair na frente à obra que atingiu
oito furos assim ó saudade gente por lá
da última semana atravessando a rua de
andador nó já tem até o suporte está
empolgando e rouba uma bola jogando uma
beleza moda não é porque na verdade eu
queria fazer um teste de discutir como o
favorito só isso pode fazer é ótimo e
bom cobaia da platéia pode ser a nossa
meta cerimônia jennifer claro que o
adversário pode ser o motivo diego
microfone vêem e ouvem e chama não
estava esperando ela já está com o
microfone nosso estava programado a
próxima entrada do agente atrapalhou na
venda
depois disso aqui pois é chique só pode
pode ficar do meu lado por salva de
palmas para gente fez de novo jogo de
palavras
agentes e moralista nunca ganha fala
três homem feio a gente tem que
abrilhantará a noite vire dia eu vou
tentar estabelecer uma conexão entre
você e sinapses assinados sei se nasci
eu vou tentar ler a sua mente pra isso a
gente tem que ter uma ligação mental
estava aí
antes de mais nada de jennifer é o
seguinte eu escrevi três coisas em três
pedaços de cartolina que o trouxe de
casa
vou pedir para você imaginar três coisas
se tudo der certo a gente vai ser
exatamente o que está escrito aqui você
acredita nisso de novo eu acredito muito
nesse meu não vai dar certo deus abençoa
tenha fé é a primeira coisa que ele fez
antes de mais nada você tem idéia do que
eu escrevi aqui não é só ter chateado é
que ainda está usando catarinense em
pleno 2 mãos noite aqui ó
já o fez ser o primeiro a gente tem que
usar o cartaz porque se a gente usar
recursos tecnológicos a pessoa vai dizer
que a gente digitou na loja lá estava o
comando de voz então a gente tem que ser
um pouco arcaico nas imagens jennifer
eu quero que você imagine pra mim por
favor isso o senhor obrigado quero que
você imagina um animal de quatro patas
pode falar qual é um cachorro muito
fácil imaginá lo é muito fácil você faz
zebra zebedee bom
ele era muito bom gostei sempre olha que
incrível porque antes de sair de casa
hoje
eu desenhei um animal no cartaz que não
é um dever que é exatamente uma zebra
[Risadas]
mas sem a marca de 2010 o volante e isso
é exatamente uma zebra um acordo ela
opina entende agora eu quero que você
imagine pra mim uma palavra uma palavra
qualquer um pode falar pode falar e
tecnologia tecnologia tecnologia
você ficaria impressionado assim último
cartaz tivesse escrito exatamente
você pensou eu acho que está escrito é
exatamente ficado impressionada muito
impressionada pode ficar impressionado
está escrito exatamente o que você
pensou se obrigados por obrigado
senhoras e senhores obrigado jennifer
chuvas para janeiro é por essas e outras
que nós somos o único grupo do triângulo
mineiro
o que nós fazemos coisas que as pessoas
não dá conta de fazer e essa é nossa
mentalismo ambientalismo maravilhoso
obrigado obrigado e bom som eu queria
dizer que diga cara é pra gente do grupo
seb é um prazer inenarrável está aqui
hoje
andré ganso ensaiando a palavra e na
rádio ontem porque eu queria sempre usar
essa palavra uma coisa especial e hoje
essa ocasião porque o tema deste ano do
pedex tem tudo a ver com o nosso
trabalho
se você for parar para pensar o que
significa a palavra sinapse
ela é derivado do grego que significa
união junção conexão e todos nós sabemos
que a comédia o riso em si é uma das
ferramentas mais poderosas para poder
auxiliar essa conexão isolado com
certeza
lindo daí quando eu digo isso que o riso
é um importante ferramenta ele é o pai é
muito importante tanto quando a gente
está sozinho rindo das coisas que a
gente acha engraçado quanto com os
momentos que a gente está socializando
com os amigos familiares e o riso tem
uma coisa muito muito legal que é uma
coisa que acontece com a gente que
quando a gente ri os nossos
neurotransmissores conversam a lei com
as novas sinapses cerebrais e libera o
que em dois finais que é um excelente
excelente é como é que eu posso dizer
assim como excelente remédio homeopático
que é o nosso próprio corpo que produzi
para poder ajudar inibidores de pressão
ou seja é uma coisa assim que o riso só
tem coisas favoráveis inclusive quando a
gente conta uma piada pra vocês e vocês
dão risada a gente está estabelecendo
uma conexão e muito mais do que isso
essa conexão é tão forte e gera uma
identificação
são vocês dão risada das situações que a
gente fala aqui porque vocês se vêem nas
situações vocês passam por diversas
situações que a gente está contando aqui
e essa identificação é muito legal
porque não é apenas a identificação a
conexão entre o comediante entre o
palestrante e o público vocês estão aí
há uma conexão entre vocês mesmos
cada pessoa que está aí são pessoas
diferentes pessoas que vêm de lugares
diferentes com propostas diferentes
habilidades diferentes têm culturas
diferentes mas todos
em certo momento no momento da risada
vocês estão todos conectados num
sentimento só olha que bonito e isso fez
a gente que se desfez a gente pensar
nela os enigmas sobre a utilidade dessas
sinapse isso porque é assassinato ela
tem que ser úteis
a gente tem que começar a refletir nos
no nosso dia a dia sobre as as ligações
que a gente faz diariamente uns com os
outros para que a gente possa utilizar
elas em benefício próprio e também em
benefício do próximo
não é então nós comediantes nós tentamos
fazer isso dessa forma nós tentamos
estabelecer uma ligação com vocês
de modo que por alguns instantes através
do que a gente diz aqui vocês possam
esquecer as tensões cotidianas e até r
dos seus próprios problemas e é essa
mensagem que a gente gostaria de deixar
aqui hoje para vocês que a gente possa
cada dia mais se utilizar da nossa
capacidade de criar sinapses para um
objetivo comum que é tornar feliz a
humanidade
muito obrigado senhoras e senhores foram
de mais esta tarde por seu pai odin
obrigado
nós somos um poema em pé muito obrigado
é uma próxima oportunidade valeu
[Aplausos]